promotions on our press team you know
how much we love to lift our our team up
here so Andrew Bates will be taking on
additional responsibilities adding the
role of senior Communications advisor
for strategic response to his portfolio
Andrew has been a tireless and talented
spokesperson on our team and in his
expanded role he will have an increased
focus on rapid response
Emily Simons has been promoted as you
all know to Deputy press secretary Emily
has been a star leading our econ War
Room work and has grown has grown into a
strong leader and mentor on the Press
team we are so proud to have to have her
stepping into the role of Deputy press
secretary and taking on even more as you
all know some of you have been dealing
with her closely on some parts of her
new role in the upcoming days we'll also
be welcoming our former press assistant
Michael kikawa who many many of you know
he'll be coming back to the Press team
as assistant press secretary Kiku as
many of us know him as very fondly will
be returning to our team from Treasury
and taking on Emily's econ portfolio and
lastly Robin Patterson who some of you
have already been working with has come
over to our team on loan from the
Department of Commerce and will serve as
assistant press secretary through the
spring she brings a wealth of knowledge
and experience to our team and we are
grateful to have her on board
congratulations congratulations to our
team on these well-deserved well-earned
promotions
so as you saw this morning the president
announced new action by the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau cfpb making
clear two types of banking junk fees
that cost Americans more than one
billion dollars annually are illegal
including surprise overdraft fees and
bounce bounce check victim fees which
are fees charged to customers who
deposit someone else's balanced check as
cfpfpb director Chopra said this morning
today's actions are just the beginning
his team is working on future rules and
guidance that would take on credit card
and other banking fees the President
also highlighted recent actions by the
FTC to crack down on unfair and
deceptive fees across Industries such as
charging consumer fees they never agreed
to or charging mandatory fees with
little or no added value like hotel
resort fees or event ticket processing
fees these fees seriously add up credit
card late fees overdraft and bounce
check fees can cost customers more than
24 billion dollars per year and these
important steps announced today will
give Americans as we say as the
President says a little bit more of a
breathing room
now it has been uh 40 days since the
death of 22 year old Masa amini in the
custody of Iran's so-called morality
police We join her family and the
Iranian people for a day of mourning and
reflection
the president said it at the U.N general
assembly and it remains true
quote we stand with the brave citizens
and the brave women of Iran who right
now are demonstrating to secure their
basic rights end quote
we are concerned that Moscow may be
advising Tehran on best practices to
manage protests drawing on Russia's
extensive experience in suppressing open
demonstrations the evidence that Iran is
helping Russia rage its war against
Ukraine is clear and it is public and
Iran and Russia are growing closer the
more isolated they become
our message to Ron is very very clear
stop killing your people and stop
sending weapons to Russia to kill
ukrainians
we remain committed to ensuring that
those responsible
for the brutal Crackdown on those
courageous protesters are held
accountable today we are announcing a
joint action between the state and
treasury departments designating 14
individuals and three entities using
five different authorities demonstrating
our commitment to use all appropriate
tools to hold all level of the Iranian
government to account specifically we
are designating Iranian government
officials who hold leadership positions
within Iran's police and prison systems
and who are responsible
for or complicit in serious human rights
abuses we are designating the governor
of the province of sistan and balochis
Balochistan for his role in overseeing
the violent response by Security Forces
against peaceful protesters we are
designating individuals who are actively
serve as commanders in the irgc for
their brutal response to protesters and
we are designating two entities involved
in censorship surveillance and malicious
cyber activity against the Iranian
people
the United States stands with Iran
Iranian women and with all the citizens
of Iran who are inspiring the world with
their bravery we will continue taking
action
to impose costs on Those who commit
violence against peaceful protesters or
otherwise seek to suppress their very
very basic rights
and with that I will turn it over to my
NSC colleague John Kirby who's here to
uh takes a few questions
there's just a couple things at the top
as you know President Biden was pleased
to welcome
Israeli president Isaac Herzog to the
White House earlier this afternoon the
two leaders discussed the enduring
strength of the U.S Israeli partnership
all the ways that we can deepen
cooperation between the two countries
and of course our unshakable commitment
to Israel's security
I also consulted on a wide range of
global and Regional issues of mutual
concern including the threats posed by
Iran and its proxies president
emphasized that his administration's
pledged to ensure Iran never acquires a
nuclear weapon they also celebrated the
forthcoming conclusion of a historic
agreement concerning the maritime
boundary dispute between Israel and
Lebanon and that was mediated by the
United States President Biden praised
Israel's statecraft and their courage
and noted that the agreement will set
the stage for much more stable and
prosperous region as well as being able
to harness vital new energy sources for
the world
the President also made clear his
commitment to advance peace and
stability in the Middle East and
highlighted U.S support for Israel's
further Regional integration into the
Arab world he emphasized the importance
of taking steps to de-escalate the
security situation in the West Bank
um and underscored that a negotiated
two-state solution Remains the best
Avenue to achieve a lasting peace he
also underlined the need to take
continued steps to improve the lives of
Palestinians which are of course
critical to peace security and
prosperity in the region I think you
know just a second I think you know uh
he's meeting with the senior uh defense
leaders right now this is part of a
semi-annual senior leaders conference
that the Pentagon hosts uh twice a year
bringing together all the commanders of
the 11 combatant commands as well as the
leadership both civilian and Military of
each of the six branches of service
coming right in the wake of the release
of the National Security strategy the
timing just couldn't be better for for
having this discussion this afternoon
with these leaders and I suspect uh
you'll see that they'll they'll discuss
a wide range of issues regarding our
national security all the way from
managing the strategic competition with
China to the acute threat that Russia is
clearly posing on the European continent
to the threats the the threat of climate
change and what that's doing to our own
facilities and our own ability to meet
to meet the the nation's needs here and
around the world as well as a whole
range of other issues so lots to discuss
today and I know he's looking forward to
having that
I think uh John Green I'm hoping you
might be able to provide a little bit
more uh context of evidence about the
Green's uh allegation before that Moscow
maybe
um supporting Iran's Crackdown on its
civilian population uh what expertise
does the US believe positive providing
what evidence you have to back up I'm
not going to get into too much of the of
the
the sources of the information here at
the podium
Karine wasn't putting forth an
allegation she was putting forth a fact
uh we that we know they may be
considering uh some sort of support to
Iran's ability to crack down protesters
and sadly
Russia has experience at doing that so
we'll see we'll watch where this goes
but it's just yet another example of uh
of uh Russia and Iran now working
together to uh to to violate not only
the human rights and civil rights of
people in Iran
but of course put in further danger the
the lives of ukrainians but has that
support the gun or is it just Moscow
considering that well what I would say
is we have some we see signs that they
that they may be considering
the
the ability to help
train Iranians on cracking down on
protesters if it had not be done already
I won't I don't want to go too much uh
into more detail I would just say we've
seen signs that they may be considering
lending that kind of support to Iran but
that's just an important point of
clarification because transcript I
believe will read we are concerned that
Moscow may be advising Iran so these are
two different things where you're maybe
considering maybe advising already
considering advising
right maybe advising
thank you and then on Brittany Greiner
um I'm assuming you saw the comment from
peskov this morning uh in which he said
all contacts of the sort should be held
in quiet is this a signal of some kind
uh are you interpreting this as a signal
of some kind that they're open to
increased dialogue further dialogue or
has there been any more dialogue since
the verdict uh since yesterday's
decision court ruling I don't have
anything since yesterday's uh Court
ruling uh for her appeal to talk about
but I would tell you that the
conversations with the Russians that
they continue
um they haven't stopped and so that
channel is still open and uh and we're
still trying to use it to bring her and
Mr Whalen home
did President Herzog provide any more
specifics to the president today about
Iran's uavs or things that they have
been able to do to assist Russia inside
Ukraine did he bring that intelligence
I'm not going to go beyond the readout
Kelly uh I'll let president Herzog
characterize his side of the
conversation I know there were press
reports before the meeting that he was
considering doing that we've already
spoken to it though I mean we've already
talked about the fact that we that we
knew Iran was providing UAV drone
capability to the Russians and in fact
we already talked about publicly the
fact we know that they've got guys on
the ground they're in Crimea that are
helping provide technical assistance uh
and training support for uh for Russian
soldiers to actually pilot these things
so again I'll let president Herzog
characterize his side of the
conversation but this is a this is a
concern we've not only had and Harvard
but have spoken to publicly
thank you the Iranian foreign minister
keep repeating saying that the
administration is sending messages that
they want to re-engage in the nuclear
talks is this true and do you think the
time is suitable to re-engage and
secondary said that the administration
message to the Iranian regime and don't
tell their own people and don't send
weapons to the Russians you think this
message will resonate with the Iranian
regime
well on your first question no uh we are
not
uh
seeking or asking for uh
a new set of negotiations or
renegotiation discussions on the jcpoe
that's not what our focus on is on right
now
it's on holding Iran accountable as
Karine mentioned in the opening
statement for the way they're treating
innocent protesters in their country
that's our Focus right now not on
getting back into the jcpoa and frankly
we are just too far apart right now to
be able to have any meaningful
discussions in that regard and on your
second question I mean uh
it it uh it never ceases to amaze me
what doesn't seem to be able to soak in
uh in terms of uh message delivery to
Iranian leaders we've been very clear
um about our concerns over what they're
doing to their own people we've been
very clear about what they're doing to
enable the Russians to kill ukrainians
and to damage Ukrainian infrastructure
they're now on the ground in Crimea
assisting in that effort uh the transfer
of these drones absolutely is a
violation of U.N security Council
resolution 2231 which prohibits the
transfer of missile-related goods
equipment and Technologies to or from
Iran so I I can't I don't think we can
be any more clear about our concern
about what they're doing and we're going
to continue to work with with allies and
partners and with the UN to see if
there's additional ways to hold them
accountable Karine mentioned just with
respect to uh the treatment of
protesters another 14 now sanctions in
place just today and we're going to
continue to stay at it
uh Admiral it has now been exactly a
month a full month since the explosions
the Nordstrom pipelines is there any
update any investigations to what
happened there I don't have an update
for you Jonathan we still believe it was
an act of sabotage there's
investigations that are ongoing not
going to get ahead of them the
suggestion as to who conducted the
sabotage I'm not going to get ahead of
ongoing investigations
production over the summer did video
strike a deal with Saudi Arabia to boost
oil production look there was uh we
talked about it before the trip
um but uh that energy security was going
to be something the president talked
about when we went that we were having
conversations uh with Saudi Arabia
before the trip about better balancing
supply and demand
um and uh and obviously when you heard
the president himself uh in Jetta after
the bilateral conversation that we had
that that he was hopeful that there
would be a boost in production there was
a boost in production afterward
um what I would tell you is and I've
seen the Press reporting on this there
were discussions before the trip
obviously about a better balance of
supply and demand to stabilize the the
energy Market of course there was and we
talked about that openly
um but this recent decision by OPEC plus
to now cut the these two million barrels
certainly is in not in and Karine said
this a gazillion times it's not in
keeping uh with uh with what we believe
was the actual mathematical analysis of
what needed to be done for supply and
demand at a time when Supply is the
predominant challenge we didn't believe
it was in keeping with that and it
certainly wasn't in in keeping with the
conversations that that we were having I
did those conversations ever culminate
in a concrete deal with Saudi Arabia did
Saudi Arabia ever agree that they would
boost oil production well again I'm
going to go back to what I said before
we there were conversations before the
trip as you might imagine there would be
uh about uh about
um
an architecture that could better
balance supply and demand to include
what was what ended up as an increase in
production at the end of the trip I
think I'm just going to leave it there I
think just I couldn't follow up then on
OPEC decision because the president said
there could be consequences do you have
any update on what those might be no and
the the president's National Security
team is
um taking a look at that right now
um internal here to to the National
Security Council the looking at uh
adoptions
um
looking at this bilateral relationship
with Saudi Arabia and and what uh what
options we would like to tee up to the
president for him to consider going
forward but the President also said he
wants to talk to members of Congress and
obviously the members of Congress are
are not here in town so we're not in a
hurry we're not in a hurry and we don't
need to be in a hurry but clearly the
president believes that we need to make
sure this bilateral relationship quite
frankly like every bilateral
relationship we have with friends
partners and allies is is suited to the
national interests of the United States
of America and to the and to the
security interests of the American
people and that's what he's going to
stay focused on but no I don't have a
specific update for him staying on that
topic the Saudi energy Minister said
yesterday that when it comes to this
conversation his country is taking the
mature route he said that at the
conference known as Davos on the desert
on the global stage yes the world's
leading finances you saw it so what do
you make of the implication then that
the U.S is acting immature
I I obviously refute that of course this
isn't a you know look this isn't uh
you know it's not like some
High School romance here we're talking
about a significant important bilateral
relationship a partnership that has
survived over 80 years an important
partnership a strategic partnership we
said that even before the trip
um and I don't think talking about it in
in terms like that necessarily lends the
gravity of how important this
relationship is uh to uh to the way that
we're considering it
um
the decision was uh was regretful uh it
was as the president said a mistake to
make that cut it was certainly not in
keeping with our analysis of what needed
to be done to help better balance Supply
Demand on the market now look it we have
not seen the decision itself result in
an increase in oil prices in fact oil
prices continue to come down they're
down like 30 percent right now from June
and of course prices at the pump here in
the United States are down about a buck
20 since about that same time frame so
we haven't seen a radical effect here on
uh on prices but that doesn't mean that
that uh that that we're all of a sudden
happy about the decision at a time as I
mentioned before when Supply on the
market is the predominant challenge we
felt that this was short-sighted and
again we're gonna we're gonna obviously
take a look at the relationship going
forward and I can assure you that
whatever this relationship looks like at
the end of that process it's going to be
that where how we get there is going to
be done in a very deliberate measured
way
um keeping in mind uh our national
security interest and those are the
American people uh the American troops
and the American citizens that live over
there seventy thousand of them in Saudi
Arabia as well as the Strategic
partnership that we have had for eight
decades with Saudi Arabia all that will
be factored in if I can ask that
question on a completely separate matter
on word yesterday from the president
that the U.S has been in constant
contact with Russia the parents of
Austin Tice the reporter who's been
missing for 10 years in Syria reached
out to CBS news they asked this question
which I'll pose to you why is Jake
Sullivan not followed the president's
directive of May 2nd to get a meeting
with the syrians I'm uh not not going to
get into Jake's individual schedule what
I will tell you first of all obviously
our thoughts and prayers continue to go
out to the Tice family and obviously we
want to see Austin home
no doubt about that and we continue to
work this very very hard I I don't have
anything on Jake's schedule to talk
about but I can assure you that the
National Security team is still focused
on this live John hi we're still focused
we're still focused on on Mr Tyson
my own reserves and said that that
decision may become a painful one in the
next few months is there any indication
that they plan to further cut production
I'd have to refer you to them Jackie I I
uh I don't have insight into what you
know what their future decisions
will or won't be
what we we did propose that they not
make a decision right now and wait until
the next scheduled meeting which was a
very early uh next month so we'll see
what they end up doing at this next at
this next meeting do you feel that the
Administration has sufficient insight
into what foreign governments are going
to do given the reporting that the U.S
thought that there was a deal to boost
production through the end of the year
that the decision from the Saudis no
effect plus came as a surprise and
caused a bit of a meltdown in the west
wing and your answer just now saying
that you know don't have insight into
what they might be doing is that at all
a failure of our diplomacy or foreign
policy
no I mean there's a lot there at uh
first of all we didn't have a meltdown
um uh secondly while we don't uh we
can't predict perfectly what OPEC plus
is going to decide to do we're not part
of that cartel it's not like we don't
have ongoing discussions uh with the
Saudis and with other members of OPEC we
do and we try to get the best
information we can obviously they have
to make the decisions that they're going
to make so we'll see where where they go
on this uh on this next meeting
what I can speak to is President Biden's
priorities and that's making sure that
we continue to keep the price going down
and to reduce the pain at the pump for
the American people and to try to do
what we can in a measured deliberate way
to help better balance supply and demand
inside the global market and it is a
global market and I think that sometimes
gets forgotten
doing to increase
diesel given that the Energy Information
Administration said as of October 14th
the U.S only had about a 25-day supply
you have the Northeast and New York
already rationing home heating oil
what are we doing to prepare for the
winter and to ramp up supply of diesel
I'll take the question on the diesel
because I just don't have the the data
on that in front of me so let me take
that and and uh and we'll get back to
you on that but but writ large the
president has been working very very
hard uh to make sure that we're uh that
not only are are we ready for
fluctuations that could come and of
course the prices are going down and we
think that's important
um but that we are also doing what we
can to help our European friends and
partners who are also going to be facing
a long cold winter we have doubled our
commitment the commitment he made in
March for natural gas exports to Europe
we've doubled that commitment
um in terms of actual you know getting
things over there getting natural gas
over there and we are working with
foreign suppliers of natural gas and oil
to see if we can't help our European
Partners diversify their own storage and
supplies many of them are in fact
building up their storage capability
here for the winter the summer farther
along than others and we're working
closely with them bilaterally and
multilaterally see what we can do to
help that but I will owe you a question
on the diesel
on the dirty bomb allegations that
Moscow is making I'm wondering if you
can walk us through
some potential scenarios that the US
sees here
um as it relates to Russia potentially
planning or executing a false flag
operation do you anticipate that it's
that they will use the mere threat of a
dirty bomb by Ukraine as an excuse to
retaliate with a tactical nuclear weapon
or do you anticipate that they would
actually deploy a dirty bomb themselves
blame Ukraine and then use the tactical
nuclear weapon how does the USC yeah let
me start the question what I would
normally do at the back end and that's
to say that we haven't seen any
indications that the Russians are making
preparations for the use of a dirty bomb
or quite frankly the the use of tactical
nuclear weapons I think that's important
to get right out front
it is a common Russian play for them to
blame others for what they are doing
themselves or about to do themselves
which is why we took it very seriously
when the Russian defense minister called
the Secretary of Defense and said that
they had information that the ukrainians
were
were fixing to to uh to use a dirty bomb
obviously it's a false allegation that's
not true the ukrainians have nothing
like that in mind they have no intention
to do that so that's why we take that's
why we take it seriously now the
question you're asking is are they just
using the threat of it or are they
actually doing again we've not seen any
indications that they're making any
preps to do that I wish I could get
inside the Russian mindset here and tell
you exactly what they're thinking with
respect to why they put this out there I
can't do that
all I can do is tell you we took it
seriously we've spoken about it publicly
we're monitoring it as best we can as
best we can and we're going to make sure
that we can continue to do what we have
to do to help Ukraine defend itself or
are you preparing for both of those
scenarios
we are making sure that Ukraine can
defend itself against a range of threats
that the Russians are posing inside
Ukraine and I think I'm going to leave
it there and lastly
um do you you've made clear that Russia
using a tactical nuclear weapon would be
crossing a very significant line do you
view the use of a dirty bomb as Crossing
that same line
the use of a dirty bomb would would
cause
would cause significant casualties
depending on the size of it and and
certainly uh follow on uh casualties as
well from radiation exposure
um
I'm I'm not going to classify it one way
or the other except to say that it would
be yet another example of Russia's
brutality on the Ukrainian people
another level of atrocity if they were
to do it that that would have to be
dealt with and properly and there would
have to be properly held accountable
accountable for
um does the White House agree with
President zielinski's comments um this
week that Israel needs to step up its
support for for Ukraine and specifically
to provide air defenses that's for
that's for the Israelis to decide uh you
know there's more than 50 some odd
Nations that are providing some measure
of assistance to Ukraine most of it in
the security realm weapons non-lethal uh
money uh that secretary Austin holds the
Ukraine contact group meeting now I
think he's had six or seven of them and
here's the thing about it every nation
that comes to that meeting
they do it on their own terms and they
decide for themselves what they're
willing to provide to Ukraine so not
long ago we were all talking about
Germany because uh you know there were
there were issues about what Germany was
doing or not doing and Germany has
evolved its own contributions over time
we have evolved our contributions over
time I mean when the war first started
we were all talking about Javelin
anti-tank missiles and Stingers right
now we're talking about Advanced rocket
systems and howitzers and air defense
capabilities that they clearly need so
the war changes the capabilities change
with it and every nation state that's
providing support to Ukraine they got to
do it on their own terms because they
have their own National Security
concerns they have to look after too so
we're not we're not cajoling we're not
arm twisting we're not poking we are
asking and we're holding these Ukraine
contact group meetings to provide a
venue and a vehicle for our Nations to
come forward and contribute but they got
to do it on on their own and look the
relationship with as you saw today with
Israel is very very strong unshakable as
we like to say and we respect that
Israel has to make these decisions for
themselves and just to follow up on that
I mean the U.S has put billions of
dollars into iron
that that technology that the US has
significantly funded should be used in
in Ukraine that is going to have to be a
decision for uh the Israeli leaders to
make but for our part we're going to
continue to we have provided air defense
capabilities to the Ukrainian since the
beginning of the conflict We are
continuing to do that we'll continue to
look forward for other look at other
capabilities that they might be able to
use and it doesn't just have to be
systems coming from the United States or
even systems that the United States
helped fund it could be air defense
capabilities that other nations have
that the ukrainians are more more
familiar with they're better trained on
they you know they have they have you
know they have the tech support to
support them so we're going to work
across the across the board and just
finally on on Israel do you agree with
Senator Robert Menendez that the
inclusion of far-right lawmakers in a
governing Coalition in Israel would
threaten U.S ties and threaten pieces
the the kind of government that the the
the
Israeli people uh put in places up to
them it's a democracy they get to decide
that we're confident in this bilateral
relationship and the strength of it uh
we're confident that uh no matter who
the Israeli people uh elect uh that
we're going to be able to work with them
going forward because there's an awful
lot of shared challenges
uh thanks John I want to follow up on uh
Trevor's question in regards to
Ukraine's request for Israeli air
defense system
um so I guess I just want more detail
does the president sure you do does the
president understand that Israel cannot
poke Russia too much considering it's
security interest in Syria or I mean you
said there was no arm twisting but was
there even um a conversation about
asking president Herzog or asking Israel
to reconsider about supplying these air
defense system I'm going to lead the
conversation to the readout in which you
heard the president say today
we are not taking a position where we're
trying to put a guilt trip on a country
to contribute a specific capability to
Ukraine we are talking and they talk
today about Ukraine of course uh we're
talking to countries all around the
world uh about about what we can
collectively do to support Ukraine and
certainly what they're willing to do to
support Ukraine but it's got to be their
decision
the follow-up on uh the the drones the
Iranian drones
to the council but does the
administration believe that it that Iran
by doing these transfers is committing
or at least complicit in uh war crimes
or violating International there's a we
as well as uh some of our partners at
the UN have called for an investigation
into this exact issue so I'm not going
to get ahead of that we do think it
should be that it should be investigated
but you can go online and look at 2231
yourself and it clearly says no transfer
of of missile related items Goods
technology or equipment to or from Iran
clearly they they're they're doing that
in inside uh inside Ukraine and to help
and to help Russia I think
we're stepping back just a little bit
this is you know Karina alluded to this
at the top it's another this whole
relationship there's another uh
indication of how isolated both nations
are from the rest of the International
Community it's also an indication of two
things in my mind one Putin has no
intention of sitting down at the
negotiating table anytime soon and two
that his own defense industrial bases
has been hurt now by the sanctions and
Export controls that he has to rely on a
country like Iran to provide these uh
unmanned aerial Vehicles which are we're
not talking about uh
ISR intelligence surveillance
reconnaissance platforms that uh that
can that can image things below these
are basically Kamikaze drones they're
meant for one purpose and one person
purpose only and that's to go hit a
Target go kill people go destroy
infrastructure that he's doing that
speaks to the brutalities willing to
continue to prosecute this war certainly
no interest in sitting down and that he
is having trouble in his own defense
industrial base that he has to turn to
another country like that on the
regional air defense system that the U.S
is trying to help facilitate in the
Middle East can you give us a little bit
more details what kind of buy-ins do you
have from Gulf States uh is it going to
be one network with all the partners in
there or is it going to be a hop and
spoke up returning to centcom perhaps
and whether the latest decision by OPEC
plus and the rising tensions between the
US and Saudi might complicate this
effort I'm sorry was this about
integrated air and missile defense we
still believe that that's a and it's an
important capability that we'd like to
pursue it was uh it was on the agenda
when the president went uh to the Middle
East in in July it's still on our agenda
of things to to explore uh Central
Command is working on through uh through
the modalities with the with our our
partners in the region we still think
it's it's a it's an idea worth pursuing
for this no and there hasn't been I mean
it's not the this is not the kind of
thing that you're going to be able to
slap together and just do in a couple of
weeks integrated air and missile defense
means netting together a series of
sensors as well as kinetic capabilities
interceptors missiles and the and the
launchers that put them uh up into the
air netting all them together in a
coordinated way so that everybody shares
the benefit of the missile defense
capabilities of your neighbor and given
the fact that Iran's ballistic missile
program continues to improve and grow we
still believe there's a lot of there's a
lot of Merit in that idea just to follow
up on the Iranian drones is the U.S
considering additional sanctions um over
the supply of those those bills to
Russia in addition to what was announced
today well we've the sanctions today
were really about the the way they're
treating protesters you saw I think it
was last week I think we did Issue some
additional sanctions with respect to uh
to their provision of these drones to to
Russia we're not taking additional
sanctions off the table I don't have
anything to announce today but clearly
if and when we do that we'll make that
public and follow up on the nuclear
talks you've said that it's not the
Focus right now but does the lack of
urgency at this stage indicate that the
Administration has given up on the talks
well I'd push back a little bit on the
lack of urgency what I said is not our
Focus right now our focus is on holding
the Iranian regime accountable for how
they're treating their own people
and we're just too far apart I mean the
Iran continues to make demands that have
nothing to do with the nuclear deal that
they want put in there and we just
aren't there
as I said in my opening comments uh in
the meeting that the president have with
President Herzog we reiterated that our
our commitment the president's
commitment to making sure Iran cannot
achieve a nuclear weapon obviously
diplomacy is the still the preferred
path to do that we're just not in a
position where that's a uh that that's a
viable viable option right now so uh I I
disagree that there's that there's a
lack of sense of urgency we don't want
them to achieve this capability but
right now what we're focused on is the
way they're treating their own people
yeah
uh can I ask you a question if a Wagner
group in Africa a lot of officials uh
the U.S officials have been warning that
the Russian mercenaries are creating
Harvard in Mali I want you to react is
do you understand the void that they are
there to feel do you understand what do
you understand the void has been created
for the Malian government to invite the
Wagner group into Mali yeah I don't have
a lot of insight into the Wagner group's
activities in Mali so um I can take the
question for you and we can see if we
can get you an answer I just don't have
the Insight on that issue
I'll just say broadly speaking Wagner
group is very active of course in
Ukraine we know that there
most active in the donbos region that
Northeast section of Ukraine right now
and that they have and we've talked
about this before I mean they have been
recruiting fighters from North Africa
from uh the Levant area to to Aid their
efforts uh on the ground it's a private
military contractor and they're not
above that kind of recruitment effort
but as to what they're doing in Mali sir
I just don't have that for you
go ahead Sebastian go ahead Sebastian
okay thank you um can I just zoom out a
bit on Ukraine because we've had a lot
of nitty-gritty on which weapon
assistant so um Zoom yeah and I've had
this question before but I think it's
kind of a crucial one uh the the Mantra
is that the support for Ukraine will go
on as long as it takes I think it's
pretty much the wording obviously
forever presumably there's nothing that
anybody wants or could ever even plan
for so does the administration have a
clear view of what's going on now and
what's being built up is going to end in
a Russian withdrawal slash defeat
Ukraine victory
if not what is the
as long as it takes where does it go
if you're asking if if we can predict
the end of this war what it's going to
look like and when the answer of course
is no
um
what I can what all I can really tell
you is is what we see now okay
neither side
is in a position to sit down and
negotiate
uh I just went through the whole Litany
of why you know Putin is clearly
continuing to prosecute this war in a
brutal violent way uh president
zielinski has said himself
um that they're focused on their
counter-offensive operations they are
not in a position where they want to
negotiate our job our our role here is
to make sure that we continue to support
Ukraine in the field so that if and when
it comes to the table president
zielinski is also able to succeed in his
negotiations he gets to determine he
gets to determine when that is he gets
to determine what success looks like and
he gets to determine what or what he is
not willing to to negotiate with the
Russians but we're just not there yet so
our focus is on making sure he's got the
tools and capabilities he needs to to
succeed on that Battlefield because that
Battlefield success uh will no no
question have an impact on the the if
and the when and the scope of any
negotiations going forward and yes we've
said as long as it takes
quite frankly we'd like for as long as
it takes to be
4 20 today right it would be great if it
ended now but it ain't uh and uh and
until it does we've got to make sure
that we're that we're postured to help
Ukraine
uh just to sort of follow up on kind of
the conversations you've been having
about Russia and Iran it's the
assessment then that that relationship
has grown closer since the invasion of
Ukraine I think it's hard to argue that
it hasn't uh at least from a tangible
perspective
uh in terms of the transactional nature
of this it's hard to argue that it
hasn't grown closer
okay thank you John um two questions
first of all regarding the God forbid
deployment of a dirty bomb against
Ukraine I'm sure the administration
would hold Russia accountable except
Russia's not going to own up to it
they've been fighting this proxy over
since 2014. most of the attacks taking
place in the dumbass Russia was like hey
it's got nothing to do with us same with
the attack on the Northview pipeline if
we don't know who is behind the attack
how will be able to hold anybody
accountable
first of all there hasn't been one
and and and we don't and we don't want
to see one all I can tell you and this
is a that's a very hypothetical question
all I can tell you is we're monitoring
this as best we can we know that the
ukrainians are not planning are not
thinking or not or not preparing uh for
the use of a dirty bomb we know it's a
part of the Russian Playbook again as I
said to Jeremy to blame others for that
which you're you're going to do yourself
which is what gives us concern we're
going to watch this as best we can I
can't tell you with perfect specificity
that should one get used we're gonna
we're gonna know the time and the place
and the size
um and that we're gonna you know be able
to have forensic evidence right on the
on the on the ground
um about about where it came from but
we're going to treat it seriously uh and
we're obviously to the degree Russia
needs to be held to account for that
kind of activity we'll do that
that's right okay
okay question is have you uh has the
administration been tracking the un's
inquiry into your commissioner inquiry
into Israel's uh
a little war with Gaza last year and uh
the condemnation that went only against
Israel not against Hamas and is that is
that something you're prepared to
comment on I don't have a comment for
you on that today all right Brian
Toulouse and John is kind enough to stay
a little bit longer we're going to move
the 430 backgrounder so
thanks thanks John uh just to follow up
for last week
um on Ukraine and the dirty bomb we both
know those things can be very hard to
detect if it's brought to the front how
confident are we that or how confident
is the dod how accomplish are you that
that that hasn't happened and are there
additional preparations to be made to
ensure that it doesn't have
I'm confident that
I'm confident that we're we're
monitoring this as best we can
um and I say as best we can on purpose
uh because uh it's not it's not perfect
we don't we don't have uh perfect
visibility into uh everything that uh
that might be done or have to be done if
one were going to actually use a dirty
bomb and just to make clear it's a
conventional explosive device using
radioactive materials to use the
explosive device to spread that
um and a lot of it would depend you know
on on size uh and
um and uh
how much preparation was was was put
into it if in fact it was used so we're
watching this as best we can and all I
can tell you with confidence is we don't
see any indications that there's
preparations for use we certainly know
the ukrainians aren't going to go down
that path we've seen nothing that would
tell us that the Russians are at this
point uh preparing to do that at this
time and then a quick follow-up to
yesterday's withdrawal of of the letter
from uh
progressives of the democratic party
requesting a change in the status of our
relationship with Ukraine for our allies
there have been reports that that our
allies are a little concerned about our
commitment to Ukraine because of that
statement can you just State
categorically that the U.S has not
changed it and won't change its attitude
or can you make that I can say not only
have we not changed our approach to
Ukraine but we haven't seen any
diminution or any any concern expressed
by our allies and partners either uh
over uh over the Press reporting on this
letter the these these Democrats as you
know they pulled the letter back I'll
let them speak to to their decision
making but we have enjoyed uh and
continue to enjoy terrific bipartisan
support for our approach to Ukraine and
the and the kinds of security assistance
that we're providing and we're going to
need that support going forward the
president is not worried about that
great thanks John um I'm gonna try to
keep this the one question thank you um
[Music]
it may depend on your answer we'll see
um
president said today that um President
Biden would be attending cop 27 in Egypt
I was just wondering if you had any
details on that trip and any information
about what the president hopes to
accomplish in Egypt I don't have any uh
travel or schedule for the president to
speak to today second question then
um
the U.S Audi relation review you said
there's no hurry that this could take a
while the president can take his time to
do this review correctly obviously
there's some things that have happened
between the announcement of this review
and today and obviously more things
could happen yesterday we heard about
how it was noteworthy that uh Russia
that the Saudis had voted against Russia
at the U.N and had provided millions of
dollars for Ukraine today you said it
wasn't so great that the Saudis were
talking about who's mature and not
mature in the relationship you talked
about the upcoming yeah I don't think
that was helpful in Iowa
so my question is sort of are there
things that the U.S is looking for the
Saudis to do between now and their
completion of this review to shape the
way in the direction of the review are
there things that the Saudis could do to
shape the direction of the ultimate we
haven't given them like a a to-do list I
mean that's not the way a strategic
partner acts with another partner
um not at all
um I think Karine did talk about the
yesterday their vote at the U.N and they
have contributed now or agreed to commit
hundreds of millions of dollars to
Ukraine and all that's welcome as I said
to the question I got on Israel these
are National decisions and Sovereign
decisions and we respect them all and we
certainly respect the ones that the
Saudis have taken uh recently
um uh but uh but no we're not um it's
not like we have a laundry list of
things that they that they have to do or
that we're asking them to do
I want to go back to what I said before
at the risk of of sounding redundant it
is a strategic partnership and it has
been for 80 years uh and uh
nobody's talking about rupturing it we
we you know it's an important
partnership that uh that bears fruit in
the region on many different levels
counterterrorism climate change I mean
there's a lot there
um
but we believe that uh that in in light
of the decision you know that uh that we
want to make sure this relationship
going forward is obviously serving the
the national interests of the American
people as as best it can and we'll get
there
um and as I said earlier it's not going
to be rushed it's not going to be done
in a in a careless way uh we'll look at
this uh very very deliberately over time
and in consultation with members of
Congress but no there's not a you know
there's not a there's not a list
oh thank you Karine um so I got a
question about Saudi Arabia and a
question about China
on Saudi Arabia U.S citizens who's
imprisoned for a series of tweets he
said his son told me that President
Biden quote sold by father for oil by
prioritizing gas prices over his release
do you have a response to that and on
China this is a very simple question but
it's an enduring point of uncertainty
does the president's son still co-own a
company with China's government and if
not can you provide some basic
transparency about who bought that stake
and how much money I don't have anything
for you on your second question but let
me let me address her first first of all
um
uh
we understand the angst
that the family's going through
we appreciate that we respect that and
we know that they love nothing more than
than to have him back I think this was
the son who said this his father
we know in uh you know
again respect the
the pain and the anguish that that
they're going through
and
we
never lose sight of the of
of the pain that families are feeling
here back home or the trials and
tribulations of
people that are wrong wrongfully
detained elsewhere around the world is
something we're constantly focusing on
um so I would just say to that family
again we
we respect and and understand and
sympathize with the anguish we continue
to work on these cases all around the
world as as much as we can
I would refer you to the state
department for the characterization of
this particular case but it's not just
wrongfully detained America we were
concerned about all Americans that
um you know that that are held overseas
uh against their will whether it's
technically wrongfully detained or not I
I'm not going to get into this specific
case I would just say to to the quote
that you read from this end of it we
again we appreciate respect
um the anguish that the family is going
through it's never far from our minds uh
and you know we work as hard as we can
to get these cases resolved publicly
mentioning this he of course did not
mention it publicly when he went to
Saudi Arabia in July I I don't I mean he
did bring up issues of of uh of uh of
Human Rights it was like the first thing
that he brought up in the bilateral
discussion I won't get beyond that in
terms of talking about specific cases
but I don't have any additional official
statements by the president to announce
or speak to right now
thank you uh President Biden uh just met
with the Israeli president I have a
question on the killing of Al Jazeera
journalist
the U.S security coordinators report was
not an investigation it was based on the
Israeli investigation the PA's
investigation there was a ballistics
analysis done that was inconclusive none
of the key eyewitnesses have even been
interviewed why has the U.S not
conducted an independent investigation
to the killing of an American citizen
we've said from the very beginning that
we wanted it her death fully completely
transparently investigated uh and uh and
you saw that the Israeli government came
out uh and acknowledged that that she
was killed from a shot fired from an
Israeli Defense Force position
um uh in that in their investigation it
wasn't uh you know it wasn't a specific
targeting of uh of a journalist
so we also you know have been in touch
with the the with the Palestinians about
this as well but we we said from the
very beginning uh that uh that we wanted
it fully transparently investigated we
recognized that the Israelis did conduct
a thorough investigation and they made
it and they made it public if you
characterize it as a third investigation
when no eyewitnesses Nokia this has been
interviewed and there's clear video
evidence that contradicts a central
claim in the killing of the U.S citizen
well again we continue to mourn with the
family and the this obviously should not
have happened but I'm not going to speak
any more about the investigation that's
been completed
yeah thanks uh thanks John so on the the
review of the Saudi relationship review
um it partly is because we were told
that it helps Russia the the production
cut helps Russia why is the same results
or why is the same review not happening
with China which has helped buy more
Russian oil 50 more and helping prop up
the Russian economy we have been very
public about uh our concerns over uh
people purchasing Russian oil and we've
called the Chinese out for this as a
major consumer of Russian oil because it
does help keep the price higher than uh
than what we what we want
what we've done to counteract that I
mean you're talking about a specific
tactical decision by OPEC plus to make a
cut which we had analysis that showed
that wasn't the best thing to do for the
market at that time and that we did
believe benefited Russia we have been no
less transparent or candid about talking
about our concerns over Chinese
purchases of Russian oil on the market
which also helps keep uh you know keep
that price up which is why
we are working with our European
Partners to try to get a price cap in
place for the oil Russian oil on the
market so that Mr Putin can't profiteer
off it anymore
a review of the relationship between U.S
and China I'm not there's no I don't
have an announcement of a review of the
relationship you're these are literally
apples to oranges you're asking us to
compare here uh we have I mean take a
look at the National Security strategy
which we just released a couple of weeks
ago makes it pretty clear uh how we feel
about the bilateral relationship with
China it's a strategic competition a
competition that the president believes
the United States can win
um and that they're also present
specific threats and challenges in the
indo-pacific region that we have to make
sure that we're that we're ready for
um and we're not bashful about talking
about
this very complex relationship with
China there are things that we believe
we can and should cooperate with them on
climate change is a good one and they're
the ones that pulled back the bilateral
discussions that we're having at a
working level on climate they're the
ones that pull back other some of the
military bilateral working level uh uh
conferences and uh in forms that we had
um so there's tension in this
relationship we believe we can manage
that tension we believe we can succeed
in this strategic competition and again
I would point you to the National
Security strategy which I think lays it
out perfectly clear how we look at this
bilateral relationship and
with or without a review how we're going
to manage that relationship going
forward
thanks everybody appreciate it
[Music]
all right thanks John for your time
appreciate you
um okay we have about 15 minutes so Zeke
you want to kick us off did the
president watch last night's uh Senate
debate in Pennsylvania I knew you were
going to ask that question
um so I actually tried to get an answer
for you I went to the oval but the
president has had a very busy morning as
you all know with the Israeli president
uh he's hosting who's in town and so I
was not able to get an answer on that if
he was able to uh to to watch the debate
last night but I do want to be careful
not going to get into uh political
Matters from here no I I know I I always
I always preface that because just want
to be safe here we we do care about the
uh the rule of law here
um but um so just want to say that but I
I will say this you know the president
looks forward to working with the
lieutenant governor uh when he is when
he is in the Senate and so we uh to
continue to lower cost continue to
deliver for the middle class family I
could say also that you know in his
conversations that he's had with
lieutenant governor fetterman he finds
uh the lieutenant governor to be a a
strong and authentic advocate for the
middle class and as you know he has
traveled many times to Pennsylvania and
they've had events together and he's
looking forward again to to work to
continue to work with him a separate
question uh we know uh Friday the
president wants to be with the
lieutenant of the betterment in
Pennsylvania it's also the first day of
early voting in Delaware the last time
there's an election in Delaware the
president had to make a last-minute trip
up there to go to the primary
significant taxpayer expense does he
plan to vote early or on Election Day
look the president as you as you know
believes that you know people's right to
vote is incredibly important and he uh
clearly exercises that right and I don't
have anything to preview on his schedule
about when he's going to be voting and
as when that happens we certainly will
you will all know but I don't have
anything to share on the timing of when
he's going to vote he certainly will
vote I just don't have a timing on when
just a really good qualities question of
given the amount of time that the
president has spent with fetterman and
the conversation that is happening today
in the wake of last night's debating
performance does the president have any
concerns about has he ever raised uh
either a conversation with you that
you've been a part of or with others
here at the White House any concerns
about his health so I'll say this it um
with in personal conversations that the
president has had with the lieutenant
governor the president has found him to
be impressive uh incredibly bright and
talented person who's just as capable as
always to carry out his office the
duties of his office as we know he is
Lieutenant Governor currently and has
great ability and heartfelt concern for
the people of the Commonwealth and that
is what the president has observed
himself that is uh you know as as is the
case before and is the case today and he
respects the courage and the honesty
that he sees from the lieutenant
governor that he's experienced in their
conversation in their relationship over
time and we have we have of course as
relates to your question about uh his
health seeing the same comments from
independent medical experts that you all
have noted and uh that the improving
symptoms he is have to do with the
speech and hearing not all with the
cognitive function so again he thinks
that he looks forward to working with
the lieutenant governor in the future
and um and sees him as an authentic
individual who is fighting every day for
the middle class and finds him
incredibly impressive
um Kevin the president last week in
Pittsburgh when we were traveling with
him said that he did think Democrats
would be able to hold this on it does he
still think that today given last
night's debate performance I mean look
I'm not going to get into analysis here
there are people out there who are who
are political pundits who who are
clearly doing that every day for the
next uh next two weeks or less than two
weeks so we're not going to get into get
into that into those specifics here's
what the president believes he believes
that uh the American people have a
choice there's so much at stake for uh
for our country and uh and he believes
that the choice is very very clear he
believes that uh Democrats and
Congressional Democrats and and the
president have a lot to speak to and
you've seen that across the past several
several weeks from this president he's
talked about student loan he's talked
about economic recovery he's talked
about uh today even the junk fees and
what his administration is doing to make
sure that we give a little bit breathing
room for the American people he's
talking about lowering costs we see gas
prices as Kirby was saying has come down
about a dollar and 25 cents a gallon
because of the work that this president
has done so he believes and let's not
forget the inflation reduction act that
only Democrats voted on that's going to
lower uh health care costs that's going
to really put put in a great effort in
fighting climate climate change and also
lower
energy costs so for him he believes and
also Congressional Democrats because you
hear them talking about it as well in
their districts and states have a lot
that they have delivered for the
American people and that's going to be
his Focus these next couple weeks as
it's been these past several months just
one more question um given you know
polls showed that voters at this point
the primary concern heading into the
midterms is inflation and the economy by
a two to one margin voter trust
Republicans more than Democrats to
handle the economy I wonder given this
sort of majority sentiment voters is the
president considering making any changes
to his economic team after the midterms
no
today the rank and file and the
Brotherhood of railroad signalment voted
61 against the tentative agreement that
was broken by the administration to
State the railroad works
the White House's reaction to that and
are you concerned that strike is ahead
so a couple of things I I we I do want
to give a little bit of a lay down of
what we think here the unions that have
not ratified and the railroad employers
have agreed to a cooling off period that
extends well into November giving them
adequate time to continue their work and
ensuring that our economy is under no
immediate threat the president remains
focused on protecting American America
America's families farms and businesses
by avoiding a rail shutdown that is our
priority of course when it comes to
these discussions both sides have said
they share that desire as well as the
president has said for months any
shutdown would be completely
unacceptable it is the responsibility of
the parties involved to resolve this
issue and that and any idea that kicking
this to Congress will result in a quick
or favorable outcome is this deeply
misguided that is our view from here
these unions rejection of the current
proposed contract does not mean we Face
an immediate rail shutdown that's not
how we view it but it does mean that the
union and the employers have additional
work to do unions are democratic
organizations as you all know we stand
ready as we did earlier this year to
support the parties in their efforts we
continue to urge both sides to work in
good faith and avoid even the threat of
a shutdown we remain laser focused as
before on taking any appropriate steps
to ensure that our America's rail system
keeps moving so our families don't don't
have to uh to suffer from this this is
now the second Union to have the ranked
file reject content of agreement is the
president himself going to get more
directly involved in this so look the
administration is in regular contact
don't have anything to share about the
president's involvement specifically
with the parties our Administration are
in regular contact with the parties who
are dealing with this matter of course
and we stand ready we stand ready like
we did not too long ago earlier this
year as I just mentioned to support the
parties in their efforts we continue to
urge again both both sides as we did
during that time as well to really
operate in good faith
uh the president's frequently talked
about transparency and so is this
Administration uh does the president
believe that fetterman should release
his medical records I've been asked this
question and I leave that over to uh the
lieutenant governor to make that
decision
just curious if the president feels that
um uh the lieutenant Governor's decision
to participate in that debate was an
important moment in terms of welcoming
people who have disabilities into the
public sphere and whether that was
important symbolically look the
president uh as I said is very
impressive by his courage
and
that he sees from lieutenant governor
I'm not going to get into any analysis
of if he should have or should have not
but clearly you know when you are in
those positions when you are a
lieutenant governor you are also a
leader and an and uh on many levels and
uh and so again you know we are
impressed by his courage we are
impressed by what he's been able to
accomplish these past several months and
you know the president will will
continue to work with him down the road
it's great I wanted to ask you about
leader McCarthy's comments that a
republican majority would not write a
blank check as early as you created my
colleagues are reporting that McCarthy
has been reassuring Republican lawmakers
that his comments about Ukraine Aid that
that he wasn't planning to abandon
Ukraine Aid and that he was simply
calling for more oversight of federal
dollars I'm wondering if the
administration accepts that
interpretation or if you have any
comments on it and also whether McCarthy
or his office have reached out or if
you've had any conversation with them
about the future of Ukraine Aid so I'm
just going to repeat what the president
said when he was asked this question
because I think he he touched to uh the
question that you're asking me
um you know he said he understands why
people have concerns the cost to support
Ukraine is great but also we have to
understand
that that uh that because of our support
for Ukraine it is a lot bigger than just
Ukraine right we're talking about a
democracy we're talking about ukrainians
who are fighting for their freedom we're
talking about an unprovoked war that was
started by President Putin and uh and
and you know the par and we all
understand that our partners our allies
understand that and Congressional
members understand that too because
remember this the support that we have
seen has indeed been bipartisan and just
to continue what the president had said
he said it's about supporting NATO and
all of Europe it's about making sure
that Putin is not able to succeed
through his brutal actions and our
support for Ukraine will remain strong
until the end of this war so we are
committed to supporting Ukraine during
this time and that we are impressed by
their bravery and we're going to do uh
everything that we can to continue to
give them that assistance just given the
significant possibility that Republicans
will retake a majority in the House have
there not been any conversations between
the White House and leader McCarthy's
office about the future of Ukraine Aid
in the wake of this so I'll say this I
don't want to get too much into
hypotheticals from here but I'll say
that we have kept that line of
communication open throughout these past
several months with Congressional
members remember this is a bipartisan
effort and we appreciate the bipartisan
effort and that's what we will continue
to work towards okay Kelly what's the
White House in any way surprised by the
performance of the lieutenant governor
in the debate
um I know that people here including not
just the president but others have been
in touch with him but was there any
surprise in terms of how he performed
given the auditory processing given the
high profile of the evening and that
sort of thing
was it a surprise to the White House at
all so look it's it's it's been a busy
day uh as you know you guys have been
watching the President he gave a speech
on junk fees uh which is going to be
incredibly important to the American
people sir saving uh American uh people
24 billion dollars so that was something
that he was certainly focused on the
Israeli president is here who he's
hosting as you all know so it's not a
conversation that we are we are
currently having here internally but I
will remind you that the president was
just with uh lieutenant governor just
last week I think a week from today when
we were in Pittsburgh and the president
talked about the bipartisan
infrastructure legislation how it was
able to uh really uh help to rebuild the
Fern Hollow a bridge as we remember back
in January uh fell uh really just
collapsed and thank goodness no one was
severely uh hurt and because of the work
that this president has done we're able
to build uh rebuild that that bridge in
a year's time and so or just under a
year to be exact so that's kind of our
focus our focus is how we're going to
continue to to do the work that we have
been doing for the past several months
again the president in his personal
conversations with lieutenant governor
he finds him uh to be
an authentic uh really
um Brave individual you need to have any
additional
um captioning service or anything like
that to help facilitate that
conversation well you guys I mean you
guys saw him I think some of your
colleagues were there when we went to
Philadelphia to the um to the fundraiser
and so your colleagues were there and so
they could speak to that themselves uh
and so you know I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna get into what he shouldn't do not
do medical that's not my place to do
that is for uh the lieutenant governor
to answer on his uh on his own for
himself but again the president looks
forward to working with him down the
road
um on student loans I was wondering is
the White House making any preparations
for the possibility that the court of
appeals could block um President Biden's
student student loan debt forgiveness
so right now as you know we've talked
about this a few times when you see when
we look at what has occurred with the
court it is a temporary court order as
you all know and I've talked about this
earlier the eight circuits uh temporary
order does not prevent bars from
applying for student student debt relief
at student studentaid.gov so people
should go there studentaid.gov again and
we encourage eligible borrowers to join
the millions of Americans who have
already applied but the the order
doesn't prevent the Department of
Education from reviewing these
applications and preparing them for
transmission to loan services it is also
important to note that the order does
not reverse lower Court's dismissal of
the case or suggest that the case has
Merit at all so it merely prevents debt
from being discharged until the court
makes a decision so we will continue to
move Full Speed Ahead we understand how
important the president's policy is uh
because we again it's going to give
families a little bit of breathing room
and let's not forget it's going to help
90 of the bars that it's going to help
are going to be folks who make less than
75 000 so we're going to move Full Speed
Ahead uh in the process getting prepared
again it's a it's a temporary order
thanks I'd like to follow up on
something you were asked Monday about
presidential press conferences it's been
since January since the president has
held a press conference here at the
White House
um or is this administration at all
concerned that the scarcity of press
conferences by this president has in any
way LED to some of the misinformation
that has been uh out in the public and
can we please get him in here
I mean look I I understand the question
you guys have to ask the question about
press conferences duly noted uh and so
we again appreciate the question but the
president uh took questions he literally
took questions while he was getting a
needle in his arm yesterday in getting
the new vaccine so he certainly uh uh he
certainly takes questions from all of
you uh and uh and he he he does it often
I understand of having a a uh a more you
know you know uh more more
well I mean look um the president is is
happy to take questions he does it
pretty regularly uh I duly noted on the
press conference uh but again this is a
president who has uh has not has not
shied away uh from taking questions from
from all of you uh and so I think you'll
he'll continue to do that almost every
day he'll continue to to make sure that
uh I'm sure on his own we'll continue to
take your questions
okay but again I'm not going to get
ahead of of of him of where we are with
with the process but again the president
uh takes questions from all of you
almost almost every day
seems great
um you had just said that there are no
plans to adjust the economic team after
the midterms so I just want to ask a
follow-up can the administration then
say when Americans can expect to feel
relief from inflation is there a date
they can look to so
um I will let the experts speak to that
I'm not going to get into uh into what
when when that's going to occur right
but we have seen some relief over the
past several months we understand there
is there's more work to be done but look
the president has been laser focused on
doing the work every day to lower costs
for the American families because he
understands what inflation is doing uh
to American workers American families
and so he's going to continue that work
we I just talked about gas prices has
that has that that has gone down about a
dollar 25 a gallon for the past several
days it's going to continue to go down
that is saving American families about
130 bucks per month that matters last
week we talked about hearing aids that's
going to how we're lowering cost cost
hearing aids cost about three thousand
dollars a pair what the president did
last week is going to hurt to help
pardon me uh tens of millions of
Americans and that matters we're gonna
the junk fees gonna give Americans a
little bit more breathing room so look
we understand
that there's more work to do we
understand that families are being
squeezed by what's happening currently
with inflation but again we have seen
some moderation I believe we'll continue
to see that don't want to get too much
into into the economist world but uh but
because of the president's economic
policies we we have made sure the
president has made sure that we don't
leave anybody behind that we have a
strong labor market that unemployment is
at the lowest that it's been in 50 years
and that matters and we should talk
about that as well as well as
acknowledging what American families are
going through I'm just gonna okay all
right guys thanks everybody